okay so yesterday we did this fox news
has gone silent on ivermectin's story
and i explained to you that very early
on 300 plus mentions of ivermectin by
fox news host saying it's good and
people are
being treated by it and it's being
covered up and all this different stuff
and then we got real randomized
controlled trials which as dr stephen
novella told us it would sort of be our
gold standard for evidence on medication
and the randomized control trials say
ivermectin doesn't work for covid and
zipped their lips fox news and everybody
goes completely silent like it never
even happened
until
yesterday
this is the next level in gaslighting
fox news propagandist sean hannity
is now saying
i warned my audience about ivermectin
the studies don't say that it works
this is such a brazen rewrite attempt to
rewrite history he can't be allowed to
do it
it's classic revisionist history
uh and media matters put together this
great article hannity's new lies that he
warned his audience about ivermectin uh
we have a clip which they put together
you're going to hear hannity now just a
couple days ago say
i was telling people
there's i don't know about this
ivermectin thing and then you're going
to hear all the times he talked about
ivermec dinner some of the times check
this out by the way that i had i've been
telling people i've ever met and linda
is that not the one thing that i kept
saying there's not a single study that
that i've seen that shows that it works
100 percent
as well as other proactive treatments
and practices were already helping cover
19 patients all across the country now
when you say ivermectin is helping
covind patients you're saying it works
therapeutics hydroxychloroquine
ivermectin regeneron when you talk about
ivermectin and regeneron and incredible
therapeutics that are now being used to
treat not just breakthrough cases but
all cases that includes yes the model
colonial cocktail no by the way mono
colonial is just one of it's it's it's
one of my it's almost better than
trump's rum reservoir for rum
remdessevier as regeneron the eli lilly
version of regeneron even yes
hydroxychloroquine ivormectin and listen
this is my business so i i'm constantly
reading they've never heard of regeneron
or ivermectin ivermectin
hydroxychloroquine that show that taken
early it can mitigate symptoms of coven
19. when you say ivermectin mitigates
the symptoms of covet 19
you are saying it works you're not
saying
in some limited place it seems like it
but be careful because it's not really a
trial
this is
classic revisionist history
they get thr not hannity but in total
fox gets more than 300 promotions of
ivermectin they say not only that it
works but that it's a conspiracy to
prevent it from being used i mean going
above and beyond what the evidence shows
and then hannity goes
i've been saying be careful about this
from the start i said it because we
don't know that it works this reminds me
of when trump
in 2018 it's a very dystopian line
said you can't even believe what you're
seeing but it's all working out and just
remember
what you're seeing and what you're
reading is
not
what's happening right even what you see
is not what's happening
how do you know what's happening well
trump tells you
but of course applied to fox news
they told you that ivermectin worked
they told you that they
didn't want you to know ivermectin
worked
they told you that
the pharmaceutical companies wanted you
to get a vaccine instead of
ivermectin or regeneron for financial
reasons even though regeneron's way more
profitable than vaccines on a per
regimen basis
and now they're telling you i warned you
all along
if you would listen to me you would have
known there's no evidence this is the
suspension of disbelief that is required
to buy into this cult
and they're willing to do it and they've
shown that they're willing to do it
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar
14 grams of protein and only four net
carbs so it's perfect if you're doing
low carb or keto or if like me you just
try to limit your sugar intake you can
build your own variety pack with flavors
like cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to
magicspoon.com pacman and use the promo
code pacman